Vsauce Kevin here but in my head where
am I
I think my consciousness is me and it
feels like a bead floating and shifting
inside my head when I wake up the bead
appears centered rested ready time to go
let the dog out brush teeth my limbic
cortex tells me it's time to eat so I
make breakfast the beam hovers behind
the back of my eyes energy drink focus
computer the bead locks against the
front of my skull by prefrontal cortex
proportionally larger in humans than any
animal in the world is considering my
future work hard today prepare for
tomorrow the bead is pressing against
the front of my head like it's
determined to burst through there are no
distractions this is my maximum
attention I am in the moment I am here
until I'm not distractions sinks in
check Twitter check facebook check clock
the day is getting away I have to go to
the store an activity that seems to
cause the bead to drift further and
further back to disconnect just get the
stuff on the list avoid eye contact I
received further back into the recesses
of my mind almost mine's less it's like
my eyes become windows and I'm peering
through them at a great distance seeing
people wondering who they are what
impossibly complex and somehow
remarkably simple journey
are they on what's the bead and their
head doing right now
what's the bead in your head doing right
a return home it's time for sleep a time
where I lose control of the bead and it
goes somewhere without me storing
organizing and recounting the events of
the day and then before I know it I
awake Vsauce Kevin here but where am i
it as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you